Hi. I think the uh objective
for right now
is just going to be to get a few more of
these environments running with uh new
ultra fast
pars. Quite a few of them.
That's Does this actually need 800k time
steps? 800 mil time
steps. I can't believe that it does,
right?
Uh, that does not work. I guess it needs
to be
mil. Did I come up with a Perf metric
for this?
lives. Yeah, bet. Whatever the heck is
happening here is
not not working.
I mean, it's kind of ridiculous to try
to max heart pull, isn't
it? I do I do just want to see if it
works,
though.
Freaking This is like nuking a
This actually will be a reasonable test
as well to see
like if we totally crush sample
efficiency. Okay. Trains in 7 seconds.
Can't
complain. Trains in seven seconds. Can't
complain.
Maybe let's get a baseline on connect
four. Actually, this one kind of
matters. Believe 30 million steps. But
I'd like to know the curve shape.
Quite slow
training. Oh no, never mind.
400k hard bottlenecked by the
environment is not
amazing. It's because of the scripted
opponent.
So, I don't expect this one to be
ridiculously fast because the end is
slow. Uh, it probably can't actually go
very much higher than 480 to be honest
because 65% m
time. This should just push it to like
90% time or
whatever. Oh, hang on. 512* 8
It should be 1024.
Not okay. Maybe it'll only push it to
like 80% of
time. 80% of the time.
Spot
is. We're not far off of the original.
Oh yeah, that actually we match the
original perfectly
fine. That is solid. And this has the
potential to be like 5x faster if uh if
we improve n per. So this is
good. I don't know if we have continuous
working. Do we have this end? Does this
end actually
fine. Okay. So, we did connect four
enduro
maiden. I'm actually interested in this
one because this is we we use this one
quite a bit actively in a lot of
research.
This is 800k train right
now. This can likely
go see numbum m is 2048. So this can
probably be made maybe 2x faster.
But then the question is going to be
whether we mess up anything else in the
process. Oh no, actually we can get this
uh quite a bit better than
that. I didn't see that we have it on
one end copy.
So we have learning rate mini badge
size. It's going to do all
this. We'll leave the rest of them
alone. And then this is going to be
We should get substantially better wall
clock. We'll see if it drains well
though. Yeah, I like this end because
it's
like it's kind of a pure exploration
task. So if we just look at the slow end
here, you get this very nice log
curve. It's a pure exploration test.
mazes training is very
stable. It's very configurable in
difficulty. It's a pretty solid
benchmark.
It's interesting that it actually does
continue to make progress like this the
whole
time. It's just a very clean log curve.
I guess that any smooth environment
should look like this, right?
Well, not really. It depends on the
dynamics of the task
itself, but uh yeah, I mean, you can
see 98% act
probably maybe 97. This is just
consistent with what we got before.
And now we run the exact same thing on
optim and we see if we totally crash
learning proof or
not. Uh I'm actually I'm seeing here
that this is a bigger model as
well. Do we leave learning rate as is or
do we use the
higher? I think we start with the higher
one and then we see
crash. If this somehow optimizes, I will
be
astounded, but I highly highly doubt it.
Yeah, it's just thrashing at point
2. Okay,
so we had
05. This
doubled. This may not be optimal.
This trains at about double the speed of
before. So this is a 2.2 mil perm model
that is training at a million and a half
steps per second.
That actually suggests to me that we can
make the neural MMO one substantially
faster. This is the same hidden size as
is used for neural
far. That's kind of just a free win
then,
right? You just make it twice as fast
with no
downsides. I actually didn't expect to
be able to train
um a model that's that size so quickly.
kind of just goes to show we should
spend more time optimizing our uh our
architecture to be
fast. So these curves match, right? But
Watch
So there is impulse worth referring to
come back
to what's neural 3
actually. It's kind of already pretty
close to what we would
expect optimal to be
right. I think the only thing is maybe
the BPT horizon could change.
a little bit. Batch size could
change. We'll run that ablation
though. We'll run that
ablation. We can't run that one now.
That's the end that takes several days.
uh
squared are aware.
with. Yeah.
1.6. I think this will go to like 25 or
something. Maybe three.
So the key here is reducing the episode
length. That's the solve time. So 45 is
Okay. Four agents. Yeah. So, you only
want 1024
second match
PF. Look at episode
length. Matches what we had
before. We just made that twice as fast.
35 mills a second.
We did snake
already. Let's do
right? This is like really
simple. This
sanity. My car pull
is. So this is just fully
solved in seconds.
solve in
uh like 5 seconds or something
ridiculous
now. Or does it
break? That's ridiculous.
mil. We did tower climb,
right? We need uh track pick up next.
Okay. Yeah, this doesn't need 100 mil,
right?
solves. Uh how many? It's four agents
each. So this is 1024.
So I think
it's this
maybe we're looking for salt within 30
mil.
solves. Triple triad, I believe, is the
last
one. And all these can get moved into
default soon, but I don't want to mess
stuff up for Aaron, who's also working
on these.
well testing. Yeah, captain. It seems
like pretty much everything is stable on
the higher mini batch size I'm learning
right
now. So, um, all the simple MS have gone
up from like 500K to 1.5 mil up to like
uh 2 something to uh 4 mil. So, pretty
much everything's doubled at least.
Triple triad seems to
take a while to learn. Oh, I think we
just never recorded this metric. This is
the win
rate. Wall time has decreased. Yeah,
wall time decreases. Like sample
efficiency is roughly the same for most
M's. A bit lower for some of them.
Um it kind of we just win. We just win
really
hard. So this is uh this is the maze end
which is a really good exploration test.
So these are the two train
curves and then these are the two train
curves when you go wall clock. So same
exact train curve but then it's just
fast.
Okay, so we have this as our
baseline and now triple triad.
stable training with large mini batches
isn't something normally
done. Well, it sure as hell didn't work
Like sometimes you take a small hit to
sample efficiency, right? You can see
the curves don't exactly
match, but they're very
close. And now this is training at 3
million steps a second. So
right the coolest thing about this my
larger mini batch size now close to one
quarter
uh 1/8 I believe default mini batch is
500k so it's 500k mini batch 32k mini uh
500k batch, 32k mini
batch. Yeah. So, this just matched Perf,
right? This just matched on
Perf and then triple triad.
This is what we like to see. Yeah, it's
pretty good. Let me send one message on
that.
All of
them. That is literally all the
Maybe. How quickly will I see things
happen here?
You also don't have um total time step
set in
here. Not going to be as big for bigger
models. The speed ups are way more for
small models. So, the cool thing with
small models, right, is that they're way
harder to optimize. Well, like it's way
harder to get small models to train
really, really, really fast. Um,
optimizing stuff gets easier as models
get bigger until you have to do multiGPU
stuff. Then it gets hard again.
300k. What is it? Drone zero reward I
think is the thing we're trying to get.
I just need a curve that goes
up.
So I mean this curve is fine,
right? Train curve looks fine,
right? Is this what you saw before?
runs. It gets 0.2 versus the scripted
bot. Or is this sitting
Okay. No, this is sitting duck
apparently.
This is such a cool environment. Like,
we've got to make the training for this
thing reasonably fast at
least. Is the new box 2D release any
faster? I saw uh on X Aaron Kata
released uh 3.1.
yet marginally using
31. All
right. Can we get some magic compilation
settings to like make it
fast? I don't
already. Are the perf improvements
buried somewhere in the 10,000 lines of
extra dependency files.
racing compiler link time optimization
is the biggest
win. So you get link time optimization
with the new puffer bindings
automatically. We should probably do um
should try the new puffer bindings at
some point. I think Syon is usually
fast, but sometimes it generates garbage
for um you know complex
stuff. But you've timed the C as well,
right? Oh, and there was a big PF dip
compared to the C, I
think. Didn't we do timing the other
day? Didn't we time the C versus the
Python and it was like slower in the
up? Yeah, I think so. Well, I'm not
saying the new bindings are for sure
going to make it faster, but it's worth
trying. Plus, the new bindings are just
nice to work with.
You no longer have to deal with Syon.
You can debug, see through
Python. It doesn't generate 30,000 lines
of crazy like Syon
shenanigans. Yeah. So, you don't need
that anymore because there's just no
Syon.
So that's kind of my solution to stuff.
Make it
simpler. I mean, this does pretty well.
This is like linearly increasing
curve,
right? It's only 100 million steps. I
mean, this should be one minute. It's
just
like stuff is not perfwise where it
should be.
happens. Also, I guess it just likes to
take forever on
eB. So
20%. Oh, I was looking at reward. Reward
is linearly
M's 16 409. Wait, hang on. This gives
you 4096,
right? Isn't it 512?
And then you have default train settings
for a pretty big network.
Yeah, I want to see if this does
anything out of the box first.
Um, like technically it should, but then
the thing is like the end is going to
bottleneck super hard.
Yeah. See, half your time's in the end
here.
end. Like we have a few other MS that
um are like this, but
side. I mean, we can use bigger
policies, I
guess. You know, I don't think that
there's probably like
What was the speed
per like the end speed per
again? It could be there's some binding
overhead because it seems really weird
that you only get 300k with 16
50. According to this, we're doing
better, but it's not showing up on the
graph for some
reason. I don't know why this isn't
logging. It's
weird. But look, we're at 1.2
already. 27.
So, all I did is I slotted in some of
our latest stuff and I improved
Perf. You can link a
sweep and compare.
One
for two
agents
[Music]
is what's that
number? 2.5 million
steps in 20 seconds.
So that's like 5 million agent steps in
20 seconds,
right? So is that
250k 250,000 step agent steps per
second,
right? Yeah. So 250k *
16 equals we should be at least getting
something decent out of this.
overhead. So this just doubled the win
rate versus the previous and the reward.
I'm now at
044 in 100
right? I don't know if it's bad to be
fair, but better.
Let's throw our latest params at this
thing.
the batch
size. See if this
works.
19 1.9 mil. So there is some overhead
but then I think that there's probably
more stuff with the vectorzation to look
at
3. Yeah, it should be like nowhere near
that.
I guess I can look at reward on this
thing. Let's get this on
Neptune. I was trying to run some
baselines for some guys on
this. Switching the bindings. It
shouldn't be that hard.
And if you're if you're not doing
anything too crazy, like you can look at
breakout, you can look at neural MMO,
like there are a couple different
options for you depending on if you need
to pass like PM params or
There's mean reward I
guess reward.
So this random Python end is
200k for some
context. It's got a recurrent policy on
it.
said gamma 0.95. Yeah, this should
totally work then.
I think that uh we're kind of at the
point where if this doesn't work, I can
confidently say, hey, the end might have
uh some issues in
it. How should I handle dynamic log
entries? Depending on the number of
drones, there may be more or less log
entries. So, if if you look at the way
we do it in neural MMO. Um, you log you
add a log when an agent dies or end of
game, I
guess. So, per agent, you add
one. Have you Let me show you how this
works real
Oops. Because it's like it's really
nice. So, you just have this log strct,
right?
You want separate logs for each agent.
Why? It's the same
right? Okay. I mean, the stats could be
one minus the other, but then if you
really want it to be that
way. Um, you just
like you don't have that many stats,
right? Do you? You could just do like
drone zero whatever, drone zero this,
and then drone one X, drone one, Y. If
you have two agents, you want to do
that.
Then just do
that. It's the same thing. It's just you
see there's no more like aggregation
code in
here. Yeah, we'll solve that when we get
there, Captain. No big deal.
Um okay then here
look actually it's very
easy I guess technically I have to give
you access to the end here
maybe unless you're reporting like a num
variable in the log but I would probably
just make it like I'll give you access
to the end in this function and then you
can just conditionally aggregate logs,
right? So, we'll be able to do that just
fine. Do it the way you're do it the way
like just with zero and one for now and
then we'll do that in the
future. Like we've given ourselves so
many ways to fix stuff at this point. It
should be pretty easy.
right? Yeah, internally does reset
because the episode length is correct.
live. That's never happened before. It
literally just closed Chrome for no
Hang on. This thing's got to be alarming
me or
They've got to have a memory leak or
something. Does this record system
stats? Does this thing record system
stats? Because I think that they just
like I think this M is just
like not implemented correctly at
all.
All
all. All right.
right.
Well, let me uh let me reopen everything
here.
And I will tell the authors of this that
uh they might want to disable crash your
uh crash your PC
mode on the M.
All right, that's their
report. That's kind of cool though to be
able to do that because like hey, this
works on every other
environment book,
right? If I didn't have this set of
parameters working on every other end, I
couldn't say that I wasn't like I
haven't screwed something up. But this
is like very very high confidence in uh
this result which is exactly the point
of puffer
lip. Look how easy that was. I just take
the latest version of puffer. I run it
on this M and we get what is almost
certainly a conclusive result.
They're telling me now that I have a
dated version of the end because they
moved debit to some other branch. Okay.
I'm pretty sure I have it right. Is this
client
I'm just rerunning it it like real quick
to make
sure. Looks like the same
result. It's 100% the same. Not dated
end, just doesn't
run. Okay.
Result looks good to
me. Let me give them one
more. Let me see one more thing if
they're going to respond to this. And
then if not, I will grab a drink and
then we will move on to next dev
segment, whatever that may be.
I have one thing that Aaron asked for
that I can do real quick.
I'm pretty sure they told me these
values were all continuous.
Got to love Twitch bots. Get out of
here. Run out of block list just on
bots.
Dude, how the [ __ ] is it that they have
everything importing everything
else? I get rid of this
How the hell is it that everything that
they imports everything else in the
entire [ __ ] library?
Okay. Is this in the requirements file?
Let me just check to make sure I'm not
the one who's a dummy
here. Okay, so they have it, but they
didn't set it up correctly.
three. Okay, now I just need the
file which they just added me to.
this. So technically the only private
thing here is this one file which is a
bunch of data. There's no way to leak
this by
mistake. All the code's open source.
file. Why do they not have this such
that it works?
What's this thing
return
features?
Config
states,
prices. Just config
states, prices, attributes, timestamps.
reader. I'll get some ppg stuff to look
at. Oh, does it do anything? Cool. Let
me fix this and then gladly
The [ __ ] is this thing? Oh, I need to
thread this
through. Does this
matter? Let's do this.